hi I'm Bethany Mota oh my gosh
I'm Michelle Phan it's time to get
creative my name is Rosanna pansino
and I have about 1.6 million subscribers
I get 2 million views per video I have
over 6 million subscribers let's get to
work hmm he tips to a successful YouTube
channel I would say online and
especially the YouTube community they
really value genuineness the main key
element is really storytelling
this is LaBella one thing the beautiful
test I think number one that's always
been really important to me is engaging
with your followers I have a really
exciting giveaway in this favourites
video if you're weird let them see that
you're weird if you're goofy let them
see that you're goofy if you're a grumpy
old fart let them see that you're a
grumpy old fart being able to tell a
story and illustrate everything so that
people can see it because they're
watching a video has to be visual so
really think about how do you want to
tell the story and button it up at the
end have fun and good luck it's really
important to me to engage with my
followers because when I first started
watching videos I related to the girls
in the video so much and I love when
they would respond to my comment I would
get so excited and it made me want to
watch their videos even more these comes
love telling me which outfit was your
favorite my last tip make something
you're passionate about oh my god I love
brownies if you like fashion make
something bash [ __ ] in the bowl I like
to upload at least once a week but most
the time I like to be more than that if
I can I will talk to you guys in my next
video it's
the fun part if you have Wi-Fi and you
have a camera whether it's your phone or
laptop my first video I used a webcam I
would say if you want to start a YouTube
channel - just go for it because I think
that's the hardest part because it's
scary you know you're gonna upload this
content that people all over the world
can see but if you want to do it then
you have to take that risk very you
don't have found out I'm still shy but
I'm getting through it yeah
[Music]
[Music]